he made the all pro
and pro bowl
uh list first team all pro in the
national football league last year he
has been the proverbial house of fire in
the middle of this 49ers defense ever
since they took him out of the third
round of the draft in 2018 he is
fred warner of the san francisco 49ers
here on the rich eisen show how are you
fred
i'm great rich how are you doing i'm
doing uh i'm doing great thanks for
calling in we've never spoken before
it's a pleasure to meet you uh i like
the way you play the football games
hey thanks thanks man i appreciate it it
looks like you like hitting people fred
is that a true story
looks like to me that's my that's my job
that's part of that's part of the deal
so
uh yeah
where do you do it where do you get this
mentality from
you know i think it's just something
that's kind of been built over time um
you know great mentors people around me
um you know i think the nfl is
is a very physical game and uh you know
the
if you don't have the mindset then
you're going to get weeded out pretty
quick so uh it's been something that's
kind of just been ingrained in me over
time and uh i just i mean i love the the
ability to kind of just put the helmet
on and be whoever you want out there
yeah it seems also to me that you um
have um
this role that you relish uh of tone
setter you know i know you got nick bosa
and you got some other guys up front in
front of you
but it seems like you are that that's
your role for the niners defense fred
would would that be a a proper
assumption do you think you
yeah i mean i try i try to you know i i
try to uh to be the guy to bring energy
uh playing and play out for the defense
and you know i think there's it just
depends on on the play it depends on the
game of of uh you know which guy or
which group position group is is the one
setting the tone on our defense you know
i think a lot of the time it's that
defensive line and not not because
they're
uh you know they're just being rowdy
before or after the play but just be
just the way that they that they play uh
you mentioned cut some of those guys
uh we have a lot of stars on that front
and uh
and i say stars in the fact that how
they play not just because of guys being
well known amongst the league um you
know and i obviously those are those are
my best friends because they keep they
make my job easy you know and keep me
clean so i can make tackles and stuff
but um yeah i i do uh i do take a a
large responsibility
been so much made obviously of uh your
defensive coordinator the last couple of
years he was at this very moment uh last
year a freshly minted uh hot uh
coordinator candidate and head coach
with the jets now
and robert sala walk me through d'amico
ryan's who's a a familiar name for a lot
of nfl fans over the years remembering
from his playing days but what about him
as the dc right now for you and what
he's done uh you got a good story on
that fred for me uh well you know i i
think something that's well known uh you
know just
i think for obviously everybody
everybody that's been around the niners
um you know he came in as a linebacker
coach the same time that i came in uh my
first year as a as a linebacker for the
defense we've grown in this thing
together
and you know we me and him know each
other really well and i think that's why
we have such a great um connection and
and we work so well on on throughout the
week and on game days but d'amico is is
as as first class and
um you know just as great as they come
seriously uh you talk about a guy who
played the game at such a high level
and you know is now coaching at the
highest level you know finishing in the
top three as a defense
in his first year um you know and i
think that's just a product of
the standard that he set you know and
there was already a standard set here by
robert sala
you know who i have a great amount of
respect for and admiration for but
i think the fact that d'amico is able to
come in and put his own twist on it
uphold the standard even raise the
standard um is amazing you know and i
think that's
that's why we all i mean we we we love
the way that he coaches and he teaches
and that's why we're able to play so
hard on sunday because we believe in
everything that that he preaches to us
let's talk about this past sunday fred
warner san francisco 49ers linebacker
what happened in the locker room
halftime because oh my gosh it looked
like a totally different team came out
and played that third quarter and got
you back into a game that you eventually
won in overtime what happened at
halftime
yeah uh you know i was i wish i could
say that there was all this screaming
and yelling and guys trying to rally
each other right but um
you know it really wasn't uh there
wasn't much that needed to be said you
know i told the entire team after we
kind of brought it up i said you know
there's no tomorrow if we don't win this
game that this is going to be our last
game and so
if if anybody in that moment had kind of
felt like they they wanted to reserve
something you know uh heading into that
last 30 minutes like this is the time to
kind of just let it all out
uh we understand that football
especially in the nfl is all about the
turnover battle uh we need on defense we
needed to take the ball away and offense
obviously having to um keep the ball and
and and scoring it in that first that
first drive after the half was was huge
even that three points before the half
was
um was really big for us um and so i
think once we kind of got that momentum
going and then the defense we just
needed to get off on third downs you
know tighten up in the back end
and as soon as we got that interception
by emanuel mosley uh i think that's what
kind of
you started to see the game kind of go
our way a little bit yeah man i mean you
got your punters kicking you got your
receivers running i mean it's just
everybody's just doing what they have to
do here
to get things done uh what was it like
for you again i know all alpha
males and all football players are
control freaks in a way but you're
standing there and you watch jimmy g
take the field with your offensive mates
uh 88 yards 87 seconds to go and the
season's on the line what was that
walk me through your
your moments there fred you sure yeah i
mean it was it was incredible i mean
just all the way through honestly
and and jimmy
coming up big exactly where we needed
him to and you know he the fact that he
came back from that that thumb injury
and uh you know it's not something that
i had that same exact thumb injury back
in the nineteen when we went to the
super bowl and obviously it's different
when you play linebacker compared to
quarterback i couldn't imagine him
trying to grip a football
because that tendon is exactly what you
need to grip things and so
um you know it's just incredible stories
all along the team of guys coming off
kobe list and and back from injuries and
stuff and
um you know in that moment it was just
like
you like you said like you feel kind of
helpless but at the same time you have
complete trust and belief in your
teammates to get the job done uh you
know to make sure we we extend our our
uh our season yeah and again after last
year where you didn't even
you were playing home games in
in in the home of a division rival i
mean uh if and on the road for for as
long as you were and what a horrible
year that was despite your personal
success
so
what are you like is this house money
for your team right now what do you
think
succeed nobody's
you know you you're you're you're that
team nobody really wants to face i mean
i had michael irvin on earlier uh fred
warner um i had michael on before you
know he's a dallas cowboy hall of famer
as you know i said let's be honest the
niners of the team you the last team
that you'd wanted to face right and he
said yes
he fully admitted that you know that
you're that team right fred
well i mean it sounds flattering for
sure um
you know i do have a lot of confidence
in our team but i mean you you could say
the same thing about like let's let's
say the roles were reversed and cowboys
were at the sixth seat and we were at
the three seed you know
who's the last thing you want to play at
60. you know you don't want to play the
cowboys like they're
they're talented in every single
position that on their entire team like
you can list little little stars at each
position group so
you know
it it's going to be a battle it's going
to be the biggest one of the year
obviously which you know that's what the
playoffs are
and it's going to be two
two dogs is going at it and i think it's
gonna be a four four quarter football
game uh back and forth and we're gonna
have to play our best game if we want a
chance to win when you speak to your
teammates as a leader do you do you
think about it like night before this
one would tell the guys when i got on
the field or you just let the you let
the moment live for the moment fred yeah
i think i think just let you know living
in the moment you know and uh i think
every every week's different every
opponent is different um and i think you
can't like even thinking back to our
playoff experience back in 19 i can't i
can't really just
pull on that experience to try and
translate it to this one because it's
much different you know like back then
we were the we were the one seed we had
a we had a buyer first
uh we had a bye week in the first week
and everything ran through uh san
francisco and now we're we're listed as
you know quote-unquote the underdogs and
having to go into a a powerhouse team in
dallas and and try to win a game so you
know every every situation is different
and you got to take it as it is and um i
know i know sunday it'll it'll all come
together all right don't take what i'm
going to ask as an insult
how about that as a setup
all right
hardest hitter on the team
fred warner hold on a second fred warner
george kittle
devo samuel
oh wow
those are my those are my three options
those are the three options friend yeah
hardest hitter on the san francisco
49ers unless you you want to give me
another one that i'm leaving out well i
gotta i gotta just i gotta just say
myself then you know and
that's just just as cocky as i am
did i hear did i hear like a little
laugh when i said kiddle did i hear
something like that no no no no no no no
listen uh those guys are unbelievable
and
my true answer out of those three i'd
probably actually say debo sandy
which is funny because
he's the receiver and you got a
linebacker to tie it in but right um you
know i think back to that play on the
sideline him against uh jalen ramsey and
jalen gave it all he got but debo was
just is just a different beast um
you know it's going to take more than
one to bring him down he doesn't do that
in practice to you right fred i mean
like that doesn't happen right you know
he knows better than that
[Laughter]
i i'm wondering though do you sometimes
watch the film of what devo does to
others and think for a split second like
i'm kind of glad that guy's on my team
like dude
i'm glad a lot of those i'm sure
you kidding me like you look at trent
williams for example and the things that
he does to right to d linemen and
linebackers i always think back to that
clip against against hicks last year in
that first game i'm like
thank goodness he's on my team not bad
well have a great time man i can't wait
i will be watching i can't wait for this
game you obviously know the the history
of it uh before you you know you even
you know existed but um
it's gonna be great i can't wait for it
and i hope this is the first of many
times we chat thanks for calling in fred
appreciate it yeah no doubt rhys i
appreciate it thank you you bet that's
fred warner
of the san francisco 49ers taking on the
dallas cowboys just talking to him just
got me all fired up
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here